a weekend trip they say a weekend trip
we're gonna be there for a few days but
I feel like I basically packed
everything Matt and Jenna on their way
so I'm gonna go take Maddie for a walk
and then we're gonna be on our way
snapchat oh what's going on with this
hey Justine hi what's going on guys
we're going to the mountains there we
are and are you proud of me because I
was actually ready on time no I'm beyond
impressed if you can just do this all
the time now usually we wait on Justine
for a while but she's ready to go I'm
excited I'm ready
we're in the car max training the drug
you'll be - I'll Drive I'll push this
whip would you really yeah that's our
it's only a trick okay so I guess I'm
not driving which is probably a better
thing Maddie is so comfy and so sleepy
Maddie you're not asleep I forgot he was
here he's so good he really is a very
good boy he just gets so excited when he
sees people and he just doesn't know how
to control himself how long till we're
there uh not at the time is just like
standing still because we haven't really
been moving that
so it says two hours in 14 minutes
that's a long time what would you be
doing nice
two hours it's not that long you really
think about it to out at me yeah I'll
just be dramatic for the vlog
mommy's got to go get Starbucks it's
very important
can you get your paws off the pants this
is our well I guess that's our second
stop our first stop was it in and out
which I snapped on my spectacles now I'm
coming to put my shoe on stop stopping
it in and out
there's Mac and oh hi look at him hey am
i get a breakfast sandwich what about
you is not all I have time probably to
get one as well
well what do we get to drink though I'm
gonna get us all coffee needs peppermint
I need peppermint in my life I ate some
candy so I don't want anything sweet
whoa
this is a maple glazed ham sage
cornbread stuffing an apple sausage on a
buttery roll it's the breakfast treating
sandwich
enjoy thank you when I fall into my own
in a heartbeat
we're about ten minutes out I'm keeping
my eyes on the road I can't wait to show
you guys the cabin that we're staying in
it's gonna be a really really fun week
Jenna
show them the view showing the view turn
down the exposure what awesome EU
J and bling goals Buster's themes on
something strange in a neighborhood
who's naughty gonna call
I just got such a pretty time-lapse no
we're just gonna take the drill now for
a quick spin before it gets dark
we're off to the grocery store in this
house great oh we're going to Mom's
everybody this is really really exciting
now we have wood right so we don't need
to buy wood oh wait Oh deliver our what
yeah we don't have a wood delivery yet
how we have no one no wood we should
maybe get some wood no no I paid for
four days where the wood four days of
101 oh it's chilly we got a list of
items we need to get we have only a few
minutes to get them because Alison Edie
JB are gonna be at the house yeah it's
just well at least I only have a tiny
camera I don't look like I think it
comes out in full effect why does your
embarrassment come out I just get easily
embarrassed in public please stop
should we all separate them Alison's
incredible she made a list shared it
with us look at this and you can click
things off at the shared list so if
somebody else gets the item it'll be
updated horrible at this top it twice
I'm confused by your bread selection
table why was D what's wrong
you think this is what this is I don't
know there's something different for me
butter of it believes it's butter do we
want one that is butter that's you
that's too big it's a little one but I
mean oh oh
founder this was like the quickest
shopping ever we got so much stuff dude
made a soup
good man Matthew oh nobody saw that
oh god this is heavy let's go see Maddie
so my mom is in the garage oh yeah whoa
okay hi
doodle upstairs you know what that means
yep hey he's trying to find everybody oh
gosh I'm just a butt so I'm sure you've
already seen the cabin tour on that
John's Channel and probably who knows
everywhere else because you guys always
beat me to the videos this is our main
little living room
here's Jenna's room the kitchen is
beautiful there are antlers everywhere
and I'm worried that Maddie is gonna get
so excited and try to eat them set a
bone he's eaten here's the kitchen
the lovely upstairs guys it's really
cold in my garage room I just wanted to
say this place has a lot of very unique
little knickknacks of these handcuffs or
is this
this is something you put like on a
horse or something my handcuff expertise
says these are vintage handcuffs
handcuffs are now yeah yeah let's just
put these down the rest of our guests
are arriving I hear JB hi hey what's
going on
vlog how are you this is LA right now
they're doing the mannequin challenge
wow it did take us a really long time to
get here but not that one about leaving
early
I was pestering them I was ready I was
packed my bags were sitting by almost
the door and that made us take two takes
of picking up the bag so he could get a
shot first he's like put them back down
put those put those back down yeah get
it for the vlog and how long to take you
guys again here uh GPS said two hours
this morning got in the car said almost
three hours and took me six hours oh
thanks took us for cuz we need to have a
serious discussion I'm worried about
Matt because he just told me that he
didn't want us to make a fire because we
already did too many cool things for the
vlog today so he was worried that we
wouldn't have anything cool to do
tomorrow so he wanted to not vlog us
making a fire for fear of I'm not sure
we might need to have an intervention
like I'm worried about it we're
concerned there's a lot of crazy
decorative pieces here
you're definitely summoning some spirits
I'm doing my snow dance is this
somebody's backpackers as a decoration
I think it's decoration this is just you
just wear this when you go to the
bathroom yeah it's quite interesting
this is great this it's like math
luggage speak to the vlog for a second
and I hope you keep this in the video
Justine has been very mean to me today I
wanted to put on Christmas carols in the
car
Merry Christmas I don't like listen you
can retire no I absolutely love
Christmas this floor will be love
Christmas better stay in the vlog so
that everybody knows that Justina is a
very nice person but she's being mean to
me today well because what what did I do
you do things that I did you tell us we
weren't allowed to film making a fire
because we already did too many cool
things in the vlog today yeah you gotta
save making a fire for tomorrow that's
unreasonable we make the fire just don't
put in the videos that we put in the
video tomorrow this is unreasonable
request it took us a really long time to
figure out how to get heat down here it
was so cold I was bundled up freezing I
was like I don't think I'm gonna sleep
down here I thought I was gonna just
sleep on the couch or I have no idea
Mady is all bundled up ready to go to
sleep
the heat is working finally I'm gonna
get in bed and edit this room is really
cool it's a little bit creepy though
because this deer is literally like
right above my bed like I don't know how
I feel about this
yeah I have a good night
hey guys today we're you're hanging out
at Dancing with the Stars I am so
excited so this is the the Red Room head
room check out the sign that's where we
are where everyone gets their makeup
done everyone comes in here for quick
hair changes quick push-ups
yeah I feel like we should probably all
just do a nice little